tengo una matriz y una matriz con la que
voy a empezar este vídeo y aprendimos
hace ya varios vídeos que su espacio
fila
a veces se le llama el espacio renglón
es lo mismo que el espacio columna el
espacio columna de a transpuesta muy
bien tengo el espacio columna de a
transpuesta y si yo a este a este señor
le sacó el complemento ortogonal también
vimos en algún vídeo hace ya tiempo que
esto es el espacio nulo de nuestra
matriz a muy bien y por otro lado si yo
tengo el complemento ortogonal del
espacio columna de la matriz a esto no
es otra cosa más que el espacio nulo de
la matriz a transpuesta que este de aquí
es el espacio nulo izquierdo
espacio nulo izquierdo esto lo vimos ya
hace algunos vídeos que como hace tres
vídeos quizá
y bueno la pregunta que ahora queremos
abordar es cuál es el complemento
ortogonal del espacio nulo de nuestra
matriz es decir en términos matemáticos
nos preguntamos quién es si yo tengo
aquí el espacio nulo de la matriz quién
es el complemento ortogonal y la verdad
es que con lo que vimos en el último
vídeo ya tenemos todas las herramientas
para poder responder esta pregunta y lo
que vimos en el último vídeo es que si
yo tengo el complemento ortogonal de un
sub espacio vectorial y obtengo su
complemento ortogonal esto no es otra
cosa más que regresar al sub espacio
original entonces si yo tengo aquí y si
yo quiero calcular el complemento
ortogonal del espacio nulo de a pues
esto va a ser simplemente el espacio el
complemento ortogonal y aquí tengo el
espacio no lo de a que es el
cumplen el perdón en el espacio fila de
atrás debe a que es el espacio con
columna de nuestra matriz a transpuesta
y esto con el complemento ortogonal pero
si queremos obtener el complemento
ortogonal de un complemento ortogonal es
regresar al espacio original entonces
esto finalmente es simplemente el
espacio columna de a transpuesta que
esto tiene nombre y de hecho es de hecho
es este de acá arriba que es el espacio
fila verdad
es el espacio fila y esto está muy
agradable el complemento ortogonal del
espacio nulo de una matriz es el espacio
fila de esa matriz ahora bien por otro
lado qué ocurre si yo quiero calcular el
complemento ortogonal de el espacio nulo
izquierdo o el no el espacio no lo deja
transpuesta bueno esto el espacio nulo
no es otra cosa más que el complemento
ortogonal el complemento ortogonal del
espacio columna y si yo quiero calcular
el complemento ortogonal de esto
nuevamente podemos utilizar esta
propiedad de arriba porque el
complemento ortogonal del complemento
ortogonal simplemente es el espacio
original que en este caso es el espacio
columna de la matriz a y con esto vemos
una linda simetría del espacio nulo el
espacio nulo es el complemento ortogonal
y aquí es donde tenemos
el espacio nulo es el complemento
ortogonal del espacio fila y también
vemos que el espacio fila es el
complemento ortogonal del espacio nulo
similarmente el espacio o nulo izquierdo
es el complemento ortogonal de nuestro
espacio columna y el espacio columna es
el complemento ortogonal del espacio
nulo izquierdo así que tenemos una linda
simetría que pudimos demostrar gracias a
lo que vimos en el último vídeo